-Guys, I am so excited
about this.
We have John Travolta
on the show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this weekend is
actually the 40th anniversary
of the movie "Grease."
[ Cheers and applause ]
To celebrate,
President Trump and Kim Jong-un
sang a duet of
"You're the One that I Want."
Isn't that nice?
It's really sweet.
-Sweet. That's so sweet.
-Trump got back
to the White House today.
He walked through the doors
and yelled, "I'm home!"
And then remembered
he fired everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Actually the people
at the White House
are pretty excited
that Trump is back.
I mean, just take a look at
what they had to say.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said,
"Oh. Good."
[ Laughter ]
Chief of Staff John Kelly
was like,
"So jazzed to hear
all about the trip."
[ Laughter ]
Melania Trump said, "Wait.
He's back, like, now?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the White House
kitchen staff screamed,
"Code red! Defrost the nuggets!
Go! Go! Go! Go!
Get me -- dinosaur -- dinosaur
shape, dinosaur shaped!"
But Trump is really excited to
tell everyone about the summit.
In an interview last night
Trump talked about how
he and Kim really hit it off.
Maybe a bit too much.
Watch this.
-Could you tell
at the beginning?
What was your --
What was that first minute?
-I felt very good
at the beginning.
The relationship
was really good.
He's got
a very good personality.
He's funny.
It's been a very intense
relationship.
It's been short
and very intense.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds like somebody is going
to the fantasy suite.
[ Laughter ]
It makes sense, though.
Kim is totally Trump's type.
He's foreign and half his age,
so it's very --
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
-Hey-oh!
-"He was gentle
and he was kind."
[ Laughter ]
"I was big spoon.
He was little un."
[ Laughter ]
This is big, you guys.
It came out today that Trump's
lawyer, Michael Cohen,
might flip on the president
in the Russia investigation.
Here's a photo of Cohen.
Yeah, that's called
resting snitch face.
[ Laughter ]
But here's some good news
for the President.
Tomorrow is his birthday.
The White House is filled with
balloons,
champagne, and streamers.
He was flattered until
he realized it was all left over
from the party the staff threw
when he left for North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Tomorrow Trump turns 72.
But he doesn't
tweet a day over 12.
It's very nice.
[ Laughter ]
Actually today it was announced
that the U.S. will host
the 2026 World Cup with Mexico.
Players can either travel from
the U.S. to Mexico by plane
or just walk past the wall
that still won't be built.
It's up to you. You can choose.
[ Applause ]
Finally, guys, I saw that Uber
is working out a new feature
that can tell if you're drunk
when you request a ride.
Here's how it works.
If it's 2:00 a.m. and you call
an Uber, you're drunk.
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots!